The moment we wake up early morning and start
with our daily chores, we
depend on various items.
You may say there are many in the list!
Yes!
But most
of the items used by us are made up of a single
material collectively known as
PLASTIC!
Yes!
The tooth brush handle, the comb, plates,
bottles, lunch boxes, bodies of
refrigerators, water purifiers, laptops and
so many other articles!
The list
would be endless!
So are all these articles made up of plastic?
Yes!
But they are quite different
from each other.
So how is that possible?
Well, it is possible because plastic
itself comes in various forms.
What do we mean by this?
To understand this, let us draw two figures.
Can you tell me the difference between the
two?
Yes!
The first one is linear in
fashion.
On the other hand, the second one is inter-linked.
This type is called
the cross linking type.
But why are we studying these now?
We know that plastic is a polymer.
Now the various monomeric units in the
different plastics are arranged in different
patterns.
And what will these
patterns be?
Yes!
They are either linearly arranged or they
are arranged in a
cross linked manner.
Not only the arrangement but even the difference
in
monomeric units that make up the polymer is
responsible for giving us the
various forms.
However, plastics are usually classified in
two major categories.
Let us take two
commonly used examples.
One is the handle of our frying pan while
the other
is a simple water bottle.
What will happen when you heat the two?
Needless to say the bottle will melt within
no time, but the handle will just
heat up without much physical change.
Can you tell me why?
If both are
plastics, then why is there so much difference?
Well that is because the two are different
TYPES of plastics!
The first one which
makes up the handle is called the THERMOSETTING
plastic.
While the other
type is referred to as THERMOPLASTIC.
Looking at the incidence of heating can you
tell me the basic difference
between the two?
Yes!
Thermosetting plastics are those which DO
NOT MELT on heating.
While
manufacturing the particular article, when
the plastic is casted into mould, it
takes up the form permanently.
It cannot be remoulded later.
The two most commonly used examples of thermosetting
plastics are
Melamine and Bakelite.
And where are these used?
Melamine is known to withstand high amounts
of heat.
It is therefore used in
making tiles, floorings and kitchenware.
Bakelite on the other hand is used in making
handles of kitchen utensils and
switches as it is poor conductor of heat and
electricity.
So this was about thermosetting plastics.
What could be the properties of Thermoplastics
then?
In contrast to the
thermosetting type, these can be moulded or
simply melted on heating.
Yes!
Thermoplastics can be easily bent, or heated
to remould it into various
forms.
And do we know any such type used daily?
Absolutely!
Polythene and
PVC are the most common ones.
Where do we use Polythene?
Yes!
Right from bags to the adhesive tapes,
polythene is used in various forms.
And what is PVC?
It stands for Polyvinyl chloride.
PVC comes in two distinct
forms.
The first one is hard or rigid PVC that is
used in making strong structures
like construction pipes.
In contrast, the other type is soft PVC which
is used for
making containers and bottles used daily by
us.
These were a few examples explaining how types
of plastics are used.
But can
you tell me why plastic is a choice against
so many other naturally occurring
materials?
What properties of Plastics make it a preferred
material over others
in the list?
Well in order to know this you will have to
watch our next video!